our journey through over 100 Mayors from
across the world came to Argentina's
capital Buenos Aires to share
information and plan on how to mitigate
the impact of global warming
[Applause]
they're part of the C40 a Global Network
of Mayors taking urgent action to fight
climate change from the cities they
represent
London's mayor sadikan is leading the
group you know more than half the
population lives in cities and that's
going up
so the U.N estimates in 10 years time 55
will become 60 become 70 so that's the
reality greater urbanization now that's
a a problem but it's also an opportunity
because if we're more dense we can
reduce our carbon footprint if we change
our cities so people can walk around
cycle around use public transport rather
than ride on the cars global leaders are
set to meet next months in Egypt at the
U.N climate change conference known as
cop27 with concerns over fuel security
and Rising costs exacerbated by the war
in Ukraine potentially overriding
climate goals
Ken says Mayors should also have a voice
if they've got all the countries around
the world
how many countries are meeting the Paris
Accord in relation to reductions only
one you look at the Mayors around the
world uh more than two-thirds of Mayors
are on cause to meet the promised Paris
declaration and so you know I think
what's really important is for National
governments to see Mayors and cities as
allies not adversaries but also for the
UN to get cities and Mayors around the
table a report this week from the
non-profit World Resources Institute
says countries are failing to tackle
global warming under the terms of the
Paris agreements scientists say rising
temperatures will worsen droughts storms
and floods and that's why financing
projects in cities in the developing
world is crucial
this meeting is also putting pressure on
National governments for them to listen
to the voice of the Cities 70 percent of
green gas emissions happen in the cities
there are decisions of the cities that
have to do with transport use of energy
Recycling and I hope that this means
more financing
and to back that up the Mayors at this
meeting announced a billion dollars
worth of assistance for projects to
generate Greener energy transport and
jobs sure progress has been made they
say it's about urgent serious action in
the world's largest cities against the
threats posed by climate change